foreign
[Music]
people 40 years and older can enter they
began to throw Stone grenades while we
were standing not doing anything we came
only to pray and relax a mosque we are
coming from far away it's a shame this
is our AXA we need to pray in it they're
forbidding us from entering what do we
do
[Music]
no I wanna lose
I think what we see today is a very
serious provocation and it will
definitely lead to an escalation and
maybe this is exactly what this Israeli
government wants they want to distract
attention from their internal division
threatened from the demonstrations that
are taking place inside Israel against
this government and they want to drag
the whole region into a total total
explosion
foreign
[Music]
the Israeli police is partially blaming
quote increasing incitement on social
media networks by terrorist
organizations but we have to remember
that the Palestinians their lives
continue to deteriorate under the more
than 50-year Israeli occupation this
year is on track to be another violent
one in the occupied West Bank 93 people
have been killed so far this year and
there is a government in power now it's
the most far-right government in place
and human rights groups are saying that
this is a government that is pursuing
policies targeting Palestinians
restricting their rights
[Music]